I try to take clear digest each meal, but I forget.
Sometimes, I'll remember an hour after I ate.
Is it helpful to take it then?
How late is too late?
I don't want to add HCl to an empty stomach.
Well, the danger of adding HCl to an empty stomach is,
if you have a healthy empty stomach,
there's really not much of a danger.
But if you have an ulcer in an empty stomach,
it's going to irritate that ulcer.
It's going to give you a really bad stomach ache.
But if it's not doing its purpose,
if you're adding HCl and digestive enzymes
to an empty stomach where your food is,
you know, there's nothing in there to digest.
So how long does it take for food to go from your stomach
into this small intestine?
Well, the length of time it takes to go from your stomach
to the toilet is called your intestinal transit time.
And everybody is a little bit different.
But you want to have a total intestinal transit time
of less than 24 hours, really.
Meaning, if you ate corn on the cob today,
you want to see it in the toilet tomorrow,
the partially digested parts,
because it's hard to digest all that.
So if you don't see it in your stool for three days,
your intestinal transit time is way too long
and you're probably reabsorbing a lot of toxins.
That's not good.
You're definitely a need of a product like Clare Digest
if that's the case.
Because Clare Digest will help you break down foods.
Remember, if you're going to get nutrition from your food,
you need to digest it first.
So the process of digested starts with your mouth and you chewing.
And then your salabaric glands release talent
and you have amylase secreted.
And that will start to break down the carbohydrates.
And then you chew up your food really good
and you swallow it in the stomach.
You have HCl to help break down proteins
and partially carbohydrates.
To prepare for it to go into the first part of the swallow test
in which you have bile from the liver,
which helps break down fats.
And the pancreas gives all the digestive enzymes,
amylase and proteases to help break down proteins and fats as well.
So if you don't break your food down well,
all sorts of bad things can happen.
If you're not going to absorb nutrients well from it,
you're going to end up with gut problems.
And you're going to have more irritation.
You're not breaking down your proteins into amino acids.
You're going to end up with food allergies.
If you don't have proper HCl,
you're not going to secrete intrinsic factor,
which is necessary for you to absorb B12.
And you're going to end up with possible parasites
because proper HCl and your stomach
is your first defense against pathogens.
Not just parasites, but bacteria and viruses.
You're touching your food.
You're the air is touching your food.
Even if you're living in a septic environment,
you're still swallowing pathogens.
So your first defense against pathogenic infection
that's food board is the proper pH of your stomach
being very acidic.
And that is produced only by HCl.
So then it's a vicious cycle because you have irritation
of the stomach because of this.
And then you produce less HCl and it's vicious cycle.
So taking a product like clear digests can help you
acidify your stomach and it helps you break down
some of the foods with the digestive enzymes
and clear digest.
I like that because it also adds bile to help you
with fat digestion.
And it takes stress off your pancreas.
But that wasn't even the question
would you just shut up and get to the answer here?
How late is too late?
Well, I think if it's an hour afterwards,
you're too late, okay?
Just wait until you eat next time.
Parsley depends on what you ate.
So if you ate a big meal and it's just sitting there,
you know what it's like after your big turkey dinner,
Thanksgiving dinner, and boy, you just feel stuffed
for an hour.
An hour might not be too late.
So that food, the larger meal takes longer to get through.
So an hour might not be too late.
But if it's just a regular small meal,
an hour might be too late.
But again, there's not a harm in taking it
unless you have a very irritated stomach wall
or an ulcer, then you're going to feel it.
You're going to go, oh, okay, I'm not going to do that again.
But it's not going to damage it anymore.
It's just a matter of not being there to do its job.
But even that digestive enzymes that clear digestion
will go through your into your small intestine quickly
and will help break down foods from there.